75 percent of black kids in california
cannot read at state levels of
proficiency
50 of all kids in the
public sector public universities in
california k through 12 cannot read at
state levels of proficiency i went to
crenshaw high school that was a the
school that was featured in boys in the
hood
i just checked yesterday two percent are
math proficient and it's a school that's
dominated by the gang called the crips
who the hell sends their kid to a high
school where only two percent are math
proficient and a school that's dominated
by crips if they can get out the
majority of inner city parents black and
brown both want choice but they keep
pulling that lever for democrats they
don't give them a choice
all right
i'm in studio with larry elder that was
the shortest intro i've ever done oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah my man i see you too all right
we just did a quick live stream because
there's a little sort of up in the air
situation as to whether you're gonna
actually be on the recall ballot you are
running for governor of california we're
going to conduct this interview as if
you are going to be on the ballot i
believe you are going to believe you're
going to be on the ballot i got good
lawyers and people say possession of the
law possession is nine tenths of the law
no it's not possession of a good lawyer
is not law i got good lawyers and we're
going to beat this okay so let's just
drop all that you're going to be on the
ballot you did it
you decided to get in the game
i had people begging me there's a
gajillion people out there like fix
california nobody ever no good people
decent people ever want to get in what
finally dragged you to do it so many
people like you approached me and said
why don't you do this dennis prager
first asked me and i said
dennis hell no and he said why i said
california is practically ungovernable
we have two-thirds super majority in the
senate two-thirds super majority in the
assembly plus a left-wing governor the
environmentalists run this state the
teachers union dominate this state it's
almost ungovernable hell no then it's
like okay i understand and then i got
approached by a guy named pastor jack
hibbs also a very good friend of mine
and he made the same argument dennis did
and then a friend of mine named lionel
chapman chetwin a longtime filmmaker
also made the same argument and then
just normal people that i know in my
life my gardener my the guy that drives
me from time to time the guy that opens
the door when i come into my uh to my
office buildings from time to time
people that were that i work with and
nobody said well larry geez you have a
great life and my goodness you're
starting to make money now and and
you've got a long time relationship with
your girlfriend nina why jeopardize all
that and nobody's lived a perfect life
and i'm sure you haven't too why expose
and no one said that i kept waiting for
somebody i respect to say that
my mother and my father are no longer
with us uh my brother just died he was
my best friend he died september 13 2019
two weeks before his 70th birthday and i
know what he would have said he would
have said go for it that's just how he
is
my mom would have said go for it my dad
would have been more reluctant about my
own privacy and my own career but my
mother would have said go for it she's
been more political than i am so i
couldn't i ran out of reasons not to do
it and the more i watched gavin newsom
the more he ticked me off the way he was
sitting at that restaurant called the
french laundry
dave i never heard that restaurant until
he was there i thought it was probably
the most elite restaurant in california
it's not i thought it's the most elite
restaurant in america it's not it's one
of the most elite restaurants in the
world oh yeah an area is sitting there
incurring a tab some people say it's 12
grand i heard it as high as 30 grand
with the very medical professionals
and the lobbyists that drafted the
mandates that they were violating by not
wearing masks and by not socially
distancing at the height of lockdown
this wasn't two weeks and his two kids
were enjoying in-person private
education and he exempted his own winery
from the from the mandates and this kind
of arrogant smug entitled attitude
really started taking me off and then
you add to that the crime and the
homelessness and the hellacious cost of
living in california my dad came to
california in 1945 right after the war
he's from athens georgia and he came out
here on a run he was a pullman porter
and he
was amazed you could walk into the front
door of a restaurant and get served and
he kind of thought maybe someday i'll
make a middle note come back to
california pearl harbor my dad joins the
marines i said dad why the marines he
said two reasons they go where the
action is and i love the uniforms my dad
was in charge of cooking for the colored
soldiers he was a staff sergeant my dad
could look at a cake dave and tell you
what's in it that's how good he is
he goes back to chattanooga where he met
married my mom and he's going to get him
a job at a short order to cook so he
goes to restaurant to restaurant to
restaurant he's told to his face we
don't hire [ __ ] ghost in unemployment
office the lady said she went to the
wrong door my dad sees color lonely in
the hall goes through that door to the
very same lady who sent him out she just
wanted him to know what the rules were
he goes back to my mom and said this is
bs i'm going to la where i've been on a
run i'm gonna get me a job as a cook and
i'll send for you in a couple of days
dad comes out walks around for a day and
a half and he's told
i'm sorry you don't have any references
my dad said i need references to make
ham and eggs
so he goes to unemployment office this
time just one door and the lady says i
have nothing my dad says what time do
you open she says nine what time do you
close she said five my dad said i'll be
sitting in that chair until you find
something sat there for one day came
back sat there for half a day she calls
him up sir i've got something i don't
think you're going to want it my dad
said of course i'm going to want it what
is it she says his job cleaning toilets
and the bisco brand bread
my dad did that for 10 years took a
second job at another bread company
called barbara and bread you're too
young to remember that company is now
defunct uh two jobs ten years full-time
cleaning toilets saved up enough money
to buy a house in south central los
angeles that is now valued at six
hundred thousand dollars i just checked
with zillow the other day wonderful for
us because in our family but somebody
eighth grade dropout could not duplicate
my dad's success from the poverty to
middle class if he or she worked three
jobs that's how bad the cost of living
has become in california the average
price in california is 150 more than the
average price in america and according
to leo haney and one of the many experts
that i've
interviewed on my radio show over the
years he's brilliant econ professor at
ucla he says houses in california are 50
more than they would be but for the
environmental laws and the extremists
that have been using them to stop
construction of housing which is why we
have a housing shortage it's why so many
young people are leaving
california going to places like
tennessee and florida
and texas there's a magazine they've
called ceo magazine don't know if you're
familiar with it they've been around 17
years and based upon things like taxes
spending
unfunded pension liabilities the power
of public sector unions
and the degree to which the business
climate is friendly or not friendly
california has been rated number 50 of
all 50 states for the entire 17 years
ceo magazine has been published it is
outrageous and this guy is doing nothing
at all about it
okay so
that story starts however with your dad
coming out here because things were
better out here
what went wrong here and when did it get
wrong and did something snap you think
in the last two years because of
lockdown that really like pushed it over
the edge well yeah to answer the latter
part of your question it was a lockdown
because of the way gavin newsom imposed
these mandates against science and the
way the teachers union kept getting paid
while telling kids not to go back to
in-school learning even after cdc said
it was okay 75 percent of black kids in
california cannot read at state levels
of proficiency
50 of all kids in the
public sector public universities in
california k-12 cannot read at state
levels of proficiency i went to crenshaw
high school that was a the school that
was featured in boys in the hood
i just checked yesterday two percent are
math proficient and it's a school that's
dominated by the gang called the crips
who the hell sends their kid to a high
school where only two percent are math
proficient and a school that's dominated
by crips if they can get out the
majority of inner city parents black and
brown both want choice but they keep
pulling that lever for democrats they
don't give them a choice explain that to
me and when i've talked to black media
and i just did that the other day in
sacramento i said aren't you tired
aren't you tired of the fact that 75 of
black kids cannot read the state level
of proficiency aren't you tired of the
fact that an lausd teacher los angeles
unified public school teacher
who has school age kids is twice as
likely as non-family non-teaching
families
to put their own kids in private school
44 of philadelphia public school
teachers dave with school-aged kids have
their own kids in private school as
opposed to 10 of families nationwide six
percent of black families nationwide
it's the equivalent of opening up a
restaurant putting up a sign and saying
come on in just don't eat the food
what are we talking about here i said
aren't you tired of this aren't you
tired of a bad mouthing the cops and the
cops are pulling back
and the people who are hurt are the very
same people that the left claims that
they care about aren't you tired of this
so what is that disconnect i mean i
asked this to basically all my guests at
this point what is the disconnect
between voting lefty policies and then
not understanding that it's those
policies that are doing all the damage
because people by and large are not
policy wonks like you and i are they're
not looking at this they're working yeah
they put food on the table so people
leave and go to oregon they go to places
and all of a sudden those states become
more left-wing and they bring their
policies with them because they haven't
connected the dots there's a reason why
houses are so high it's called sequa the
california quality environmental act
that basically stopped any project for
any reason for almost an indefinite
period of time in preparing for this
race i talked to a lot of developers and
contractors
and the stories they told me larry i had
a 2 000
home development project all ready to
roll i got sued i cut it down to a
thousand i got sued i cut it down to 500
i got sued now is 200 homes 22 years
later i talked to one guy who made all
of his money buying gas stations
and when i say talk to i'm i'm on the
phone trying to raise money 75 percent
of being a being a politician is raising
money huh um
and i call him and i introduced myself i
said my name is larry oliver who
didn't know who i was i'm on radio 30
years in california in every major
market you didn't know who i was
pretty ego settling a couple viral
videos with that dave rubin guy tell me
about it he didn't know who you were
either and i said haven't you seen me on
dave rubicoo and
i said
i said one of the things i'm going to do
when i become governor is i'm going to
call a state emergency and i'm going to
suspend sequa and he goes what's your
name
sql was suspended for the
construction of the sacramento king
stadium up in sacramento for a
billionaire somehow they waive sql but
for people that want bill houses so the
average person leaving california
doesn't realize that stopping
construction of course means it's going
to be a surplus a a a deficit of homes
economics 101 uh supply and demand and
as a result fewer fewer supply the the
demand goes up and the prices go up so
young people can't get their starter
home the way my father was able to do
with an eighth grade education and
people are leaving they don't understand
the connection between the declining
public schools and the fact that you
literally cannot fire a teacher
derek chovin by the way uh however you
feel about how that trial turned out had
about 15 serious complaints against him
they couldn't get rid of him uh same
thing with the teachers
there are 300 000 public school teachers
in the state of california i am told by
experts that between five and seven
percent of them are incompetent which
means a minimum of fifteen thousand need
to be fired you know we were fired last
year two
two and took millions of dollars for
that to happen and they end up in the
worst schools i subscribe to spectrum
cable it used to irritate me how it
defaults to the la times channel i swear
to you that's why i got rid of cable
because they would every time you turn
on the box
what you had the night before it's there
but after you're sitting there you're
captive and every now and then i'm
watching this stuff and when i decided
to run for office it's local so i wanted
to get more into local issues and the
other day two or three days ago there's
this black woman who started her own
school
and it turns out two-thirds of black
parents do not want to send their kids
back to lausd they've seen how bad the
education was because they were able to
watch it online and they are ticked off
and they believe there is systemic
racism but not the normal kind of
systemic races because most of the
teachers and the administrators are
black right they believe the worst
teachers and the worst administrators
end up in the in the inner city schools
where they need the best teachers and
the best administrators and they believe
that's systemic racism so they want out
i'm the one that wants to give you out
and but i'm an uncle tom and i'm a
sellout think about it connect the dots
all right there's a reason for this okay
so on the dots the dots i think in terms
of the zeitgeist of america have been
being connected because you've been
talking about the family stuff forever
and that you got to stop throwing money
at all these things there do seem to be
more red-pilled former lefties like me
that perhaps because of the video that
you and i did where you beat me
senseless and everyone's seen it already
but but people woke up right so in that
regard are you feeling hopeful that
maybe
in place in pockets of say the black
community that weren't uh open to these
ideas i am absolutely hopeful i believe
i can explain things in ways that joe
and joe sinks back and can get again
it's not because they're stupid it's
because they're working they're putting
food on the table they're trying to get
that first starter home
but they don't realize that the
connection between this and all the
problems that they're complaining about
we talked about homelessness
what does gavin newsom and the democrats
want to do about homelessness build
homes
at a cost three four five times in what
the private sector could do a and b not
dealing with the underlying problem why
they're homeless in the first place so
even if they were able to get up and go
to the homes they wouldn't stay
meanwhile you're sending a single to the
other states cold weather climates i can
go to california where the weather is
nice people are going to treat me
humanely and i get a free home come on
down and that's what's happening i
talked to cops who tell me that many
people on skid roll aren't even from
here
yeah no we know that they're coming now
so when you see that places like venice
that was used to venice beach was the
coolest gorgeous place
trendy bohemian it's a disaster right
now drugs everywhere needles everywhere
and one of the reasons is because of
proposition 47 that the voters in
california foolishly voted for which
meant that if you still
at 9 50 or less by the way you can do it
every day yeah you're not going to go to
jail because you'll get you're you'll be
committing a misdemeanor and if they
catch you they'll give you a ticket the
whole point was and it was a legitimate
point was to get people in treatment
because many people who are stealing are
stealing to support their meth habit
but you take away the the stick of going
to jail there's no reason to go to rehab
so the cops are saying get up and go to
rehab fu why should i go what are you
going to do to me nothing so what do we
do about the da's because that's part of
it too right we have two now we have two
left wings we have two left wing da's
one in the bay area san francisco and
one in la and by the way they're both
facing recall elections and uh i also
avidly support the recall of those two
da's because they're solved on crime and
this malmowing of the police the police
are pulling back
it's called the ferguson effect now they
call it the george floyd effect you're a
cop much of police work is discretionary
you don't have to get out of the car if
you don't want to you see something
looks suspicious why get out of the car
and run the risk somebody's going to get
their cell phone video you and accuse
you of systemic racism so they stay in
the car they're answering radio calls
and that's it bad guys know it crime is
going up guess who gets hurt black and
brown people the very people that the
left claims they care about so if let's
say you win
i'm on the other when i win when i win
when you win don't be so negative no no
i'm i'm with you you said let's say
that's hypothetical
hypotheticals out here what did i say
after you win comma you want me you may
sit over there and i can interview
myself what are we doing over here come
on talk before we started i said you're
my obi wan and i'm princess leia now
you're my only hope right this is it if
i'm going to stay in this crazy in this
crazy city and in this crazy state but
what what would you be modeling this
after i mean would would you want
california to basically be modeled after
say what desantis is doing in florida
like does that look like a good model to
you well yes it yes it does but what i'm
going to do when i become governor i've
had a lot of conversations with wen
i did that for you i'll do that for you
uh when i become governor um i've talked
to a lot of people who are
um people that were in the
administration of pete wilson of
duke majon two republican governors in
the past
and you'd be amazed how much power the
governor has even dealing with the
hostile legislature of course you can
veto
this line item veto there's the ability
to declare a public emergency
and
that ability has been used many times by
this governor to impose all these
anti-science mandates right now there is
a a public emergency of housing shortage
there's a public emergency of
homelessness there's a public emergency
of schools i'm going to impose public
emergencies to get rid of these bad
teachers to suspend uh sql so that
people will not be afraid to to to build
20 000 prisoners have been released
under the supervision of this man gavin
newsom under early release for covet so
they're releasing felons while treating
builders and contractors like felons
it's ridiculous i'm going to reverse
that do you think that gavin newsom
thinks he's doing well
well how many interviews have you seen
gavin newsom had in the last several
months we've reached out a million
dollars of course not yeah how's he
going to defend rising crime how's he
going to defend these crappy schools he
wouldn't put his own kids in on a bet
how's he going to defend
basically buying buying
homes for homeless at 10 times or five
times the cost of what the private
sector can do how's he going to defend
any of that he cannot how is he going to
defend how ticked off people are about
the arrogant way he shut down this state
in the most severe way than any of the
other 50 governors have done he can't
defend that he doesn't want you
in the 33 years that buckley had his
show called firing line
the last day he ended the show somebody
said why didn't ted robert kennedy and
all the times you extended him an
invitation come on your show and buckley
said why does the bologna avoid the
grinder he doesn't want you he doesn't
want me he can't defend that he's not
going to debate me are you kidding are
you kidding so what do you need to
happen what what do you think you're on
the back
like what do you think has to happen
over the course of time i need money
it's not a ton of time i need money when
i was uh induced to run
by people that i like and respect by the
way you said mentioned prager before i
said to prager in my backyard months ago
i said dennis run i'll i'll fundraise
for you you could have parties here
whatever everything i can do you could
be on my channel what do you say get
larry elder to do that get married
get the black guy to do it
um and dennis is also responsible for my
career on radio but for dennis i met him
in cleveland when i was working there
i'm from here but i met him in cleveland
and dennis put me on the show
management heard me the rest is history
and then this also induced me to get
into this race i told dennis this
morning i was on this show i said dennis
you're going to burn in hell
what are we talking about well then
we're all going together i lost my
transition so in the two months now it's
it's money okay so you've got to make
your money okay so i was told by people
like dennis and people like pastor jack
kevs and others larry because of your
celebrity because of your uh social
media uh profile platform you got 2.5
million i think you have a little bit
more yeah they're screwing you on
twitter by the way i'm sure like i know
you're like right up there on that
you're in i have a channel called larry
elder epic times channel yeah i have 575
000 followers i've had that same number
for almost a year it was rocking and
rolling and all of a sudden dead stop
yeah no i know because me and you were
both at like 980 on twitter and i was
like i want to be not that we're
competitive or anything like that yeah
but i was like you know you know you
beat me once publicly so i was like i
gotta get to a million before him and
then they just can't get you get there
yeah
so the whole thing is about money that's
why i'm urging people to go to
elector.com notice how i didn't work
that in until just now no no it's subtle
i waited on it yeah i started doing
right away i said you know they weren't
like that was elect elders
yes
and so i was told unlike the average
politician you're not going to be on the
phone 75 of the time raising money
because you're so well known and all i
have to do is tell people that you're
going to run and all of a sudden the
money they're going to come before again
i'm on the phone 75 of the time trying
to raise money just like any other
politician there's a 34
200 limit max individual contribution
i'm sure you're going to be making that
dave well i'll have to uh and uh
i'm sure my accountant's over here you
know uh but gavin newsom does not have
spending limitations nor raising
limitations he can spend and raise as
much money as possible
shortly after it was obvious
so the incumbent can raise whatever they
want from whoever they want but by the
way the five the five-year tax stuff
that i had to return uh that that is
apparently the the problem by my getting
on the ballot uh again that's going to
be overturned i'm sure uh does not apply
to him
he does not have to return turn over
five years of his taxes just just the
just the rivals wait i'll put that one
aside but why doesn't the incumbent have
any limitations on what he can tell me
it's california downtown man
yeah chinatown jake um
but i do i have limitations on more than
that i cannot win unless i get money
from people in california and outside
california who recognize how california
goes so goes the rest of the country and
i want millionaires and billionaires to
quote bernie sanders set up pacs along
the lines of my philosophy about school
choice about what to do about crime what
to do about homelessness so that i can
spend beyond that otherwise i'm not
going to win uh shortly after it was
obvious i was going to run a union gave
this man five million dollars
um so without getting money from other
people and outside other people to set
up political action committees along the
lines of my philosophy i don't have any
hope of beating this guy so you consider
yourself a small l libertarian right yes
so i i would i've always been that and
i'm a registered republican and the
reason i registered republican about i
think it was 12 years ago i was going to
run against barbara boxer i wasn't going
to run against a libertarian they always
lose
and
by the way this is kind of my one of the
reasons i didn't want to go into
politics i had such a bad experience
then
they said go to washington d.c meet the
senate people john cornyn who's still
there and uh imhop from oklahoma who's
still there and just show them how
charming you are given your backstory
and then they'll back you as the
official candidate and the money will
come come in
the flight of dc on my own dime
i didn't want there to be any
shenanigans um and i sit there with with
cornyn i tell them about my background
and talk about my father and how he came
to california in 1945 he was a marine
and all this and they're like
i thought i'd won them over i get back
to lax phone rings we're going with
carly fiorina i said why they said three
reasons one she's a woman i said well
i'm not gonna have a sex change she's
gonna run number two she has more money
than you i said i'll give you that
number three she has higher name
recognition than you do no she doesn't
she does in dc because she was ceo of
hewlett-packard right but nobody knows
her out here in california she lost by
10 points and didn't put nearly as much
money into her campaign as they thought
so that was my only foray into politics
other than when i ran against william
moore for fifth grade class president
i took three out of four roles they're
still cleaning up the blood
um so i i just was turned off by the
whole thing about politics yeah well i
know you how duplicitous it is and many
people i thought were going to we're
going to give me money didn't and those
who i didn't think was going to give me
money did and i'm still surprised all
the time by the games that people play
and the shenanigans people play but
i am
now
old enough and i think wise enough uh
and experienced enough in life to
understand these things are going to
happen i was asked many times what is
your experience for running for for
governor
and i said what is gavin nuisance
experience he was the governor of mayor
of of uh san francisco he was eight
years
eight years lieutenant governor two
years of current governor how's he doing
there was a fellow who ran for governor
served two terms ran for president
served two terms his name is ronald
reagan came out of the movie industry
for crying out loud i've got common
sense i've got a good judgment i'm a
native californian i'm a product of
public schools i know what's wrong with
them i've got ideas what to do about
homelessness i know what we can do about
crime
i know we can do about the cost of
living so uh when i become governor i'm
going to use my powers to declare
emergencies for many of these issues we
have the same water infrastructure and
the same power infrastructure as we had
when california was half the population
because if you stick a spoon in the
ground someone's going to sued you
claiming it's had an adverse
environmental impact on the sequel i'm
going to stop all that crap so
when newsom's doing all of this like the
average person especially during
lockdowns i would go to a lot of the
rallies to open up the state and i was
meeting you know people that own
restaurants and people that own
businesses that they were not political
they certainly were not republicans but
they were mugged basically mugged by
reality and they were going i just want
to go to work
i have a feeling a lot of them can be
broken and they can move to say the
conservative side or republican or larry
elder thing but what do you think is do
you think there's something else you got
to do to get them to make that final
jump well that's why i need the money i
need to be on television california is a
big big big state and you need to be on
tv you need to be on radio but dave it
doesn't take long to find horror stories
um i mean literally they just come up to
you i don't have to go look for them the
other day i'm shooting a commercial for
my um for my ads from for uh for running
for office
makeup ladies putting stuff on me we're
both bored waiting for them to set
everything up so i'm talking about tell
me about you and she goes well i'm a
single mom
and i have a 17 year old son he is one
of the top 25 wrestlers in california
for his weight class was wrestling six
days a week and his coach was his father
figure the coach begged them not to shut
down the school and and to keep these
want these kids to keep having the
structure they were having so now the
kid is in the home with his mom cooped
up month after month after month after
month kid becomes morose becomes sullen
he had enough
integrity and a good enough relationship
with his mom that he went up to her and
said mom i feel suicidal he's now in
therapy another person on my campaign
had had a brother living in oakland had
is an important word he was a football
coach white guy most of all his players
are black coming from fatherless homes
he was their father figure they
practiced six days a week he gave them
structure
begged them not to shut down the school
system these kids need to have structure
two of them got into trouble with the
law one of whom had committed a crime so
serious he's going to be in prison for
years it would not have had to happen in
his opinion had they had the same
structure that he had before he got so
ticked off he's now in tennessee
resuming his football coaching career
they're not here
i read a piece in the la times a day or
two ago about you and uh you know
it was something like trump acolyte
something like that larry elder's name
and it ends in the most i mean it's the
media is so awful like nothing surprised
me at this point but like the last line
was in effect and there was larry elder
once again defending white people
something to that effect i'm loosely
quoting it she also she also said larry
has been uh falsely using crime stats
about black people didn't say what crime
stats i was falsely using and the one
she's talking about is when i told her
that the number one
cause preventable death for young white
men is accidents like car accidents
drowning accidents the number one cause
of preventable deaths for young black
men is homicide almost always at the
hands of another young black man now
unless you're prepared to say black
people are just genetically inclined to
commit more crime you have to ask
yourself what the blanket's going on
here and the answer is fatherless homes
there's a direct line between all these
problems we're talking about and kids
coming from homes without a father and
forget about elder i think i gave you
the stat before
obama once said a kid raised without a
father is five times more likely to be
poor and commit crime nine times more
likely to drop out of
school and 20 times more likely to end
up in in prison now how have we gone
from 25 percent of black kids being born
outside of wedlock in 1965 to 70 now
you're telling me that america's more
racist now than it was in 1965 and the
answer is the welfare state what we've
done well their answer would be yes but
your answer is right they would say yes
it's because america kept getting more
racist kept getting more things like
that after obama gets elected it's kind
of a tough argument to make them but
they make that argument and the fact is
we've incentivized women to marry the
government we've allowed men to abandon
their financial and more responsibility
that's why we have these problems and
speaking of racism
and you're quite right the democrats are
really pulling out the race card now
because donald trump improved the
percentage of black vote from 8 to 12
from 2016 to 2020 that's a 50 increase
and they are scared to death
in 27
gallup did a poll obama's running for
the nomination against hillary and
mitt romney's running for the nomination
on the republican side against john
mccain
what percentage of americans uh gallup
asked would not vote for somebody who's
black five percent what percentage would
not vote for somebody who's a woman
eleven percent what percentage would not
vote for somebody who's a mormon
twenty-four percent what percentage
would not vote for somebody who would be
72 when he became president and that be
john mccain 42 so obama had a lower
hurdle than these what three white
politicians what are we talking about
here grow up knock it off there's a
there's a sociologist at harvard he's
still there his name is orlando
patterson
back in 1991
he said america despite its flaws is the
least racist majority white society in
the world provides more opportunities
for all for blacks than any other
country in the world including all of
those of africa that was 1991 well
before obama got elected last time i was
on cnn i reminded don lamont of a
of a
polled study that was done by time
magazine and cnn
of black teens and white teens they ask
them both is racism a major problem in
america and both of them said yes then
they asked the follow-up question to the
black teens i never seen anybody do this
before
is racism a big problem a minor problem
or no problem in your own daily life 89
percent of black teens that it was a
minor problem or no problem in my own
daily life in fact twice as many black
teens said quote failure to take
advantage of available opportunities is
a bigger problem than racism end of
quote
that was 23 years ago what are we
talking about here knock it off knock it
off these guys are playing the race car
because they know that they have to
scare a 13 percent of black people and a
bunch of liberal white people uh into
believing that racism ranged a major
problem because they pulled that lever
for them 95 until donald trump came
along and said what do you have to lose
larry you're scared to death blown me
away once or twice over the years but
are you telling me that the
conservatives are not racist are you are
you telling me that the conservatives
don't hate gay people and that the
conservatives generally want to live and
let live is that is that what you're
dropping that's right that's what i'm
saying most people want people to
realize their potential why would it be
in anybody's best interest for a group
of people to be
to perceive
them as racist how is that making things
better don't you want everybody to be
law abiding
drug abstaining tax paying people
doesn't that make everything good
uh and whenever i ask people about
systemic racism and i always say can you
can you name names what do you get david
duke after that after that the list is
pretty short isn't it give me the name
who in congress on the republican side
is systemically racist give me the name
give me the name and sometimes they say
trump are you kidding me
best economy ever under trump he
pardoned jack johnson the first black
heavyweight champion that obama didn't
do despite the fact that ken burns the
lefty uh documentarian came to obama and
said please pardon this guy didn't do it
sylvester stallone please pardon the guy
didn't do it uh trump does it he also uh
commuted the sentence of a woman named
alice johnson who has done a very long
trump hotel very long non-violent drug
offense uh he put permanent funding of
historically black colleges on for
10-year footing the one that had done
that before expanded opportunity zones
dropping some of the rules and
regulations in distressed areas so that
you you invite more business if he is a
racist he needs to go back to racism
school when you were watching the state
of the union and he mentioned lowest
black unemployment of all time and then
to watch the congressional black caucus
right there like this right like to me
that was everything that you've preached
about in your 40 years doing this how
many years you've been on air at this
point 27 27 i gave you an extra 14. but
all of those black don't crack and i i
know i know it looks really good
really good but but when you watch that
moment
it must have just been like man i have
been screaming about this stuff here's
the guy doing this stuff and they dare
sit there but it's just one little
example they've been doing this for
years uh obama's mom sent him back from
indonesia when he's 10 years old to
eventually go to punahou the finest prep
school in the state of hawaii because
she wanted him to have better education
michelle obama did not go to a charter
school they didn't exist then but she
did not go to her local government
school because it was so bad she got on
the bus and went to a much better school
ice cube the rapper uh he didn't go to
his local government school he went to
taft which the time was predominantly
white so what are they telling you
they're telling you they want choice but
you don't get choice and they're
beholden to the teachers union that
adamantly opposes choice for all the
reasons i just now mentioned they don't
get their automatic dues from the
teachers union and therefore it
threatens them they couldn't care less
about the quality of education
and i mentioned the three hundred
thousand teachers uh in in uh
in
public school teachers in california and
the average year only 2.2 were fired
imagine
i told you between five and seven
percent of them are perceived to be
incompetent there are twenty thousand
cops here in in uh in la
imagine if five percent of them were bad
cops that's a thousand cops on the
streets we wouldn't put up with it we
put up with 15 000 bad teachers who
wants to do something about that we do
they don't but i'm the bad guy i'm the
uncle tom think about it open up your
eyes who's on your side now the beauty
of our of our private ballots is you can
go in there and your mailing ballot and
you can vote for a republican and nobody
has to know about it so i'm telling
these independents and democrats pull
the lever for me don't tell anybody
who's on your side i'm on your side i'm
going to tell people
well let's talk about elections for a
little bit because i voted i voted for
trump during the presidential election
and i voted against all of the tax
increases that they wanted to throw out
on us here in cali and in la but i don't
have to show an id and i was actually
quite amazed because then i thought well
i could just walk back all you need is
your name and your address i could be my
neighbor and vote the next day and the
next day and the next day
how broken do you think the whole system
is at this point and actually related to
california specifically are you
confident that once you're in and that
that the election will even be legit in
such a broken state
well i i'm confident if it isn't uh
again i got good lawyers people say
possession of the as i said possession
is nine tenths of the law and the
possession of a good lawyer is nine
tenths of the law i've got good lawyers
regarding trump if i may
a number of reporters what do you do
about the fact that you voted for trump
well i'm a republican uh i voted for the
trump over hillary uh i should apologize
for that the last time i voted for a
democrat was jimmy carter and i regret
that um and i will vote for whoever is a
standard bearer in 2024. um you're not
running against trump you're running the
avenues of running against larry elder
and that's what they try and do what
gavin newsom and his people said when
this thing got certified this is all
being driven by white nationalists now
dave you know me now for a few years i'm
allowed to think but it looks like a
white nationalist to you not a way not a
white one you in your robe in the
hollywood hills with your red wine not a
white nationalist but what do we do but
are you confident that an election would
be legit in a state that we know is so
deeply corrupt for them well i i
having been not included on the
on the ballot
for for these ridiculous reasons i'm a
little worried they're scared to death
the unions are scared the public sector
unions in particular are scared remember
when scott walker did the union reform
and and reduced their bargaining to
wages but not benefits and not uh
discipline uh and not right and uh he
also made them if you're going to get a
raise beyond two percent uh beyond
inflation you need to go to the polls
and ask the voters
he stopped the automatic deduction of
union dudes i'm going to do all of that
too and they showed up his house they
took it at this house and they
threatened him
they took over the state capitol took
over the state direction when they did
it of course not no it was just a
friendly gathering of a civil
disturbance
it's going to happen to me it's going to
happen to my house too bring it
i've been asked larry are you afraid of
being unpopular i'm a guy who's been
called an uncle tom and the bootlicker
in a sellout uh and a bug-eyed
bootlooking sellout for 27 years but
what they rarely call me is wrong that's
the word i fear the most wrong they
don't say that so bring it hold my beer
you're happy in all this i mean that's
why i love you because you're also just
happy in all of this you're fighting
because because unlike the left i don't
believe if you disagree with me you're a
bad person that's how they think of us
if you don't believe that racism is a
major problem in america you're a bad
person if you don't believe that taxes
should be raised on rich people you're a
bad human being if you don't believe
that the court should be stopped stacked
with a bunch of people who think like
soda so sonya sort of your you're a bad
person i don't feel that way about you i
just believe that you are ill-informed
you haven't met anybody like me my mom
was a democrat my brother was a democrat
both of them i got them both to vote for
george w bush twice they still didn't
change their party affiliation but i got
them to vote the right way they didn't
tell anybody yeah so i don't think
you're a bad person you're just ill
informed and i believe that the captain
of the titanic dave had he known the
iceberg was there he would have taken
evasive action i think a lot of people
don't realize the iceberg is there but
once they do they will take evasive
action it's up to me to explain to them
connect the dots explain to them why we
need choice in school why the cost of
living is so high and what can be done
about it what we can do about
homelessness it's up to me to explain
that and i believe i can do that in a
way that joe and joan six back and can
do better than almost anybody else
because i'm a communicator and i thought
about these ideas and i've written um
a column every week since april of 1998
i've written a half a dozen books
discussing these kinds of things i'm on
in every major market up and down
california from sacramento to san diego
and i believe i can accomplish this
in a way more effective than anybody
else there's some very good republicans
in there some of them are quite good
policy walks and one of them is going to
get the first call to be my chief of
staff when i win so how are you going to
bring i mean have you tried to talk to
some of them and be like guys let's all
call coalesce around somebody i hope
it's me
no we haven't um but what's happened as
i've given interviews is they've tried
to get me to slice and dice my my rivals
and i said i'm not playing that we
should turn our cannon fire towards the
prize the prize is gavin newsom keep our
eye on the prize and everything will be
just fine i think the more the merrier i
think everybody brings a little bit of
the audience a little bit of intensity
with them and our intensity level versus
the democrats off the chart that's why i
believe we're going to win what do we do
about taxes in this ridiculous state
well i'm not going to be able to roll
him back really because i'll be dealing
with two-thirds of the of the
legislature we talked about it and i
talked to a lot of budget experts
virtually almost all the budget is on
automatic pilot what i can do is stop
bad stuff you'd be surprised how seldom
a government veto is overturned i
checked when i first started not to run
i said you know they'll overrun all my
vetoes i didn't realize arnold
schwarzenegger vetoed hundreds of bills
not a single one was overwritten there
hasn't been a veto overridden since the
early 70s the first uh of the two two
terms that jerry brown had
what's the possible reasoning for that
just because they don't want to work
because because the bills are so stupid
once you veto them you hold the press
conference explain why
uh people put pressure on their local
senator their local assembly person and
all of a sudden they back down they
don't defend the bills so i can at least
stop bad stuff from happening
i can stop single payer
that's what they would love to do if
they get away with it i can stop that i
can stop some of these kinds of things
and as i said i can use my emergency
powers to suspend sql my emergency power
so that i can unleash the power of
builders i'm told by several builders
there are 500 000 units right on the
board ready to go all you have to do is
just just lift the lift the uh the
injunctions and we're ready to go larry
we got a mask mandate here in uh la
again
all against science it's la county and
the la county sheriff alex villanueva i
talked to him a few days ago said this
is anti-science i'm not going to use my
manpower to enforce it what does that
tell you
what does it tell you this man gavin
newsom has imposed all these mandates
completely against science these guys
are all about science until they're not
so this woman barbara ferrer who is the
one that actually put put this mandate
in place um what do we do about that
elected class i don't even is she
elected i'm not even sure if she's
elected what do we do about that layer
of these people like the woman who you
know voted to shut down all the
restaurants outdoors but then knew it
wasn't going to kick in for 48 hours so
then she ate outdoors yeah that was that
was she like
i protested at her house that day
i didn't want to do it but that's where
they were doing i don't like bringing it
to people's houses obviously but that
that's right you have a choice but the
point is what do we do about that class
of people because those guys seem to be
pulling the levers in some ways more
than garcetti i don't hear him say
anything about l.a anymore i mean he's
on his way to india again one of the big
things i'm going to have is the bully
pulpit i'll be able to talk about people
like that and one of one of the other
things i was told when i become governor
is to empower the republicans up there i
know they're outnumbered but if you tell
the democrat lawmakers look if you don't
get
bipartisan buy-in i'm going to veto
and so all of a sudden the bills become
much more sensible they involve the
republicans to a degree they never have
before so that's what i'm going to do
i'm going to empower republicans i'm
going to give them backbone i think
that's one of the things donald trump
did by being so politically incorrect
and telling the truth he said what do
you have to lose to black people and
they begin to say what do i have to lose
what do you have to lose i saw a guy
when i was in the bay area just on a
campaign thing
poop in the middle of the street
and then
devour his poop
do we have to do this do we have to
watch this this guy needs help
and it's not helping him it's not
helping the homeless population we need
to do something about all of this stuff
and i'm going to do that
elder because you are a professional
you're a broadcasting pro not like a lot
of people i bring in here you're a
broadcasting professional there's a
camera right there
tell that camera where you can go
and
final statement i can't remember the
website but i think it's elect elder.com
elect elder.com i'm gonna need your help
the top maximum individual contribution
as i'm just telling dave it's 34 200
so please please please some of you rich
people out there max out and some of the
people outside of california who are
very very wealthy billionaires
millionaires many of you left because of
all of this set up a pack or give your
money to a pack that's got a philosophy
along the lines of mine let's turn this
state around because we have a state to
save elect eldridge.com elect elder.com
do you like this outfit
my girlfriend wasn't here to tell me
what to wear so i i took a chance and i
did this very professional i did the
orange kind of blue thing i'm not sure
that works all right i'm going to host a
fundraiser here now i've said it
publicly so i have to do it is dave on
the record saying 34 2 maxing out i got
my talk to my account he's my thank you
right now
thanks my friend thank you thank you
and thank you so much for bringing me to
a whole new audience of young people
you've often talked about the interview
where you feel that you kind of had your
assumptions torn asunder but you also
elevated me to another level of a
popularity that i did not have i think i
told you before a young person suggested
i interview with you i didn't know who
you were yeah
i said larry get your head out of your
you know take the poll out this guy is
the man uh he's cutting edge and you
exposed me to a whole generation of
young people who did not know who i was
so i also blame you for
my feeling that i can turn around some
of these young people because a lot of
people wrote me and and look in the
comments i saw you on dave rubin i saw
you and dave rubin i thought the way
dave did and when you told him about the
stats regarding the police that the
police are more likely to to be hesitant
to pull the trigger on a black suspect
than the white star i didn't really
realize that i went back and i saw the
stats and so thank you so much david for
introducing me to a whole audience that
i never would have known but for you
honestly larry we're in this thing
together we are we really are and you
were telling me how much you loved
comics before and i got my comic
collection right there and it's like
we're in the avengers now together we
got a bad enemy to fight but they beat
thanos i think we're going to be all
right that's right
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell